started by showing you a video from this
one world government conference with
evil Palpatine talking about being a
master of the universe and all of the
horrible things that he will do to you
people
but then they oddly skyped in Elon Musk
and Elon Musk wasn't having it
one thing I should say and I know this
is called the world government Summit
but I think we should be maybe a little
bit concerned about actually becoming
too much of a single World Government
um if I may say that we want to avoid
creating a civilizational risk by having
um frankly this may sound a little odd
too much a cooperation between
governments
um you know if you know if you look at
say the history and the rise and fall of
civilizations
um the really all throughout history
civilizations have risen and Poland but
it hasn't meant the Doom of humanity as
a whole because they've been they've
been all these separate civilizations
that were separated by great distances
so I think we want to be a little bit
cautious about uh being too much of a
will of a single uh civilization because
if we are too much of a single
civilization then if we if the whole the
whole thing May collapse
it would not be good if the whole thing
collapsed now there's an awful lot of
reasons that some of the people in
charge right now are worthy of a
collapse but I don't want to deal with
the residual Fallout of that collapse
and Elon is right when they want one
world government well if you have one
structure above all of us then some
goes down over there and it's gonna hurt
you over here so again we should be
reverting back to the way humans lived
for literally thousands of years where
you were dependent on your family and
your community and everything was local
and that's not to say technology is all
evil and it's not to say that there is
no way for governments of other well
certainly of states to work together on
things and then countries to work
together on things and all of that stuff
but something is very wrong about this
thing so it's quite beautiful that that
conference ended with Elon basically
putting a poop emoji on the entire thing
because uh he happens to be the richest
guy in the world who is fighting for
free speech and fighting for the ability
for Nations to exist for a purpose other
than just giving power over to Klaus
Schwab and those other people
[Music]